I think the human race needs interaction
I think there's a lot of things going
wrong in our society and I think for
sure yeah that's part of it yeah so
Braxton you grew up where I grew up in
Wabash Indiana it's the first electrical
lit city in the world a small town the
first way first electrical lit city in
the world we had the first yeah so it's
like this we got a honestly our
courthouse is badass like our courthouse
is like a it was built and I forget what
year early 1800s but like there used to
be this light that just lit up on entire
town
and so it was a guy from Cleveland
actually that came down and gave us a
light bulb and you know stuff like that
so and this is really cool this is where
in Indiana Southern
uh no Northern very top we're like 40
minutes away from Michigan so you know
and tell me like what you what your
childhood is like growing up because
you you live a very different life than
my childhood was most people I feel like
it was
in my small town it's normal for kids to
you know grow up with drug addicts and
grow up horribly so I grew up in the
same exact situation uh
I was with my mom until like age three
or four but I was always with my grandpa
my grandpa raised me so he took us from
three to four
and then I got cancer at five
so I had kidney cancer at five
and
so I mean we just always you know we
just always looked up after that but
anyway I did have cancer at five then
after that I had cancer again at 13 I
caught testicular cancer
so then growing up in that whole time
like it was always I love my grandpa to
death but he was also a crackhead you
know so he did cracking everybody around
me always did drugs my mom was a method
she was in prison for
I don't even know how many years it was
like 10 15 years so your your family was
in the drugs bad yeah very very very bad
yeah like it's still a reoccurring thing
till this day really yeah so oh my
grandpa's clean I will say that my
grandpa's clean finally but it's still
you told me your mom yeah my mom oh did
on my birthday two days ago and I don't
know it's
I don't feel a certain way about it
because like okay this is how I know I
jump around a lot but this is how I look
at it like I'm the type of person like
people say it's tough being raised
without parents and stuff and you know
like and there's a side to it that is
but there's also a side to it like in my
mind where I'm like if you don't want to
watch me grow up and do the badass
things that I'm doing then it's like you
know
I don't I don't look at it like I try
not to look at it like oh what was me
you know like because I did have the old
man so the old man's my world he's been
there every step every Cancer every
graduation every
small thing you got it close oh yeah me
and my old man are real close I didn't
it's my grandpa but yeah he's yeah he's
my dad yeah work real real close we
muster them hunt together so like a
around this around
April first week April morel mushrooms
pop up and they're a delicacy I mean
they're the Rolls Royce the mushrooms
they're great so we got into that when I
was a small kid and then like we disc
golf and
yeah so me and the old man we do
everything together he helps me trap a
little bit
and so we try to we're best friends he's
I mean we sat on the couch I express my
day to him every day like he's just he's
always been there he's my rock he's my
blue as long as you have somebody
whether it's your dad or your
grandfather or your uncle whatever yeah
yeah so that's always good but growing
up I mean I was
I grew up kind of like I I scootered a
lot I was in this my very first thing I
ever got into a scootering and um
so I would just scooter scooter scooter
you know and I was kind of like the
skater kid so I had like long red hair
and I'd wear the tight jeans with the
spike belt you know I was
kind of like in that era of my life
and then I got to Middle School well I
was in Middle School I got to high
school sorry in high school kind of
uh
it changed me a little bit you know
because it was like the first time like
the T I lived in a small town I mean our
town is everybody knows everybody and if
you you mess up one time you know like
everybody just knows everybody about
everybody everybody
so the teachers you know they get
the tea just like everybody else in town
so they kind of knew my situation at
home so like sixth seventh and eighth
grade I was very um
I was
I was a hood you know like I just I try
to get attention in class and like just
do stupid things I was a troublemaker in
school you know until I kind of got to
high school and I was still a
troublemaker but it was more like I was
trying to express like school was my
Escape for a lot of kids it can be your
escape and it can also be a living hell
you know so
my school was an escape I knew I was
going to get fed at school like I knew I
could go talk to the teacher at school
like about anything that I wanted to
like there was nothing left out like I
felt you know like I knew I could trust
my teachers
[Music]
but I got really really close with a few
teachers and it was always the weird
teacher like the librarian for our high
school we were the closest I didn't do I
didn't read books I didn't you know like
I didn't it was just she was a very very
sweet lady and then
senior year I got the best teacher that
I could ever ask for her name is Mr
pucey
but she she she opened my eyes to um I
was a very not I didn't get to travel a
lot in high school you know my parents
were on drugs like we didn't celebrate
birthdays we didn't celebrate Christmas
like I didn't open up I didn't open up a
Christmas present until I was 22 years
old you know like we just didn't when I
was a little kid I remember one year I
got a paintball gun but like we didn't
the old man's attacker he's like here's
a hundred dollars Merry Christmas you
know what I mean it wasn't like a I woke
up and got to see the Christmas tree
this is your dad or your grandpa yeah my
grandpa that's who I call the old man
but I never knew my dad
um
my dad's never been around did but did
having cancer twice uh impact your life
today
um the way you see things
you know it probably should but no you
know the way I look at it is not to get
way off topic but I'm kind of a
religious man in a way but I don't go to
church every Sunday because I feel that
God talks to people in different ways so
I feel I'm always protected by God no
matter what he puts me through no matter
if I'm in the slums or if I'm on the
high like I feel like he's always
watching over me neither whether I go to
you know church every Sunday or not
he's yeah I don't know I just feel like
God watches over people differently and
I just feel like I'm protected
differently than most people
I mean what you believe becomes what
your reality is very often and I think
so much another big thing too is who you
surround yourself with so
I'm kind of the type of guy where
I'm a little strange I get like my brain
bounces all over the place I'm into
different things I mean so like with my
friends I see it reflect so I got
friends that
never touched a drug in their life they
go by God you know what I mean like they
go to church every Sunday and then I
also got friends that sadly they're into
drugs and
so there's kind of two ways you can go
on my town
there's always the well there's three
ways I don't guess there's many ways but
the three main ways guys go in my town
per se are they either join a union and
you know they get on you know with some
union job and you know that's a great
good life for them but very
I would say basic
I don't know blue collared kind of work
you know just kind of life and I knew
that's not what I wanted and then I look
over here and you know I got like my
uncles and my grandpa and all the
influences in my life per se they're
over here taking drugs and I'm like well
that's not what I want to do in my life
and then I look over here and I'm like
well I don't want to you know just work
fast food and stuff like that the rest
of my life so I went to um college for
culinary I went to Sullivan University
in Louisville Kentucky
you know by Associates and bachelors and
my associates that come on here my
bachelor's in Hospitality management
so I took that route and I collectively
realized you know being in like the
culinary industry like there was a lot
of people like me kind of had the same
kind of Lifestyle as me and like it's
very creative and it's a very like
stressful and like
um
I don't know just all the time
environment and then like at the end of
the night it's like
you know so you get a lot of this way
that way this way and this is how the
night ends but
being in
that was just what I'm into and stuff I
feel like I'm sort of like
here I am for a couple months hearing
for a couple months here and for a
couple months hearing for a couple
months if that makes sense like I'm
in my mind but it all comes together and
I'm just me you know
so so you're into trapping yes trapping
specifically right yeah beaver trapping
specifically so
real quick there's two kinds of traps
you can or there's two kind of Trapped
you can go towards so you know you got
your guys that they want to trap their
coyotes and their foxes and you know
I'll hit out there that's really all we
have in Indiana
um foxes and coyotes you can cocoons and
possums
and then the trapping that I like to do
is beaver trapping a very uh very very
very into beavers I love beavers I love
everything about beavers I love catching
beavers I love skin and beavers I love
making stuff out of beaver fur I love
learning about beavers I love sitting
out there and just watching beavers so I
am a God no more about beavers than me
definitely than the average person you
know what is it about beavers that
draws you in
um honestly how different they are you
know like I've always felt like um
different myself so I remember the first
time I saw a beaver you know they got
those big old web back feet with that
big old tail and they could slap and
they got those big yellow teeth it was
just like what what the [__] is that
thing you know what I mean it was like a
mud rat I don't know it was just it was
weird so I mean very industrious and
yeah very and just I mean if you see if
you saw what they did there I mean it's
they can transform it into just like a
construction crew I mean that's what it
looks like you can see it you know
and it just always intrigued me and I I
just remember being in the history like
I am I love history I can't I can't get
enough of History especially like older
like fur trapping Mountain Man history
that's
the one I'm into the most you know but I
just remember always hearing you know
beaver fur was built or America was
built on beaver fur and I was like what
the hell's about a beaver you know what
I mean like what the hell are these
Beaver but like I said the first time I
ever laid eyes on a beaver I'll never
forget it because I mean I was in
I was in just shocked two per se and I
was very intrigued you know like what
does this creature do you know they move
at night they only eat trees like what
the hell is going on here so it's just
always all that and then when I got into
the trapping finally it started catching
them
that's when I mean you're playing games
with Beaver you're not
you're you could have a trap center
right and what most people don't realize
is real quick not to get off spam but
they think it's mean trappings being
traps are no different than having a
collar on your dog it just looks a lot
worse because it's on his foot I mean
when it's held yeah it there's sometimes
I come back and there's the Paul in my
trap or something where they'll rip
their own you know Paul out but
for the most part it's just holding them
and it does look bad because you know
they're down in there blah blah
then you have Connor they're scared for
their lives exactly and they know like
and you gotta think you know like when
they get caught their first instinct is
to get out of whatever has them and so
once they calm down
it they I mean they're not dumb they
know hey but at some point you're
killing the animal yeah so there's two
kind of traps you can do there's a
foothold where you can catch them by
their back paw and there's a kind of
bear where it's
instant death trap which I've caught him
in tails and stuff before but it'll
catch them right behind his shoulders
and they just you know kind of hang
there
those are the ones I like to use because
you know when you you get up to them and
you gotta kill them it's another story
you know and sometimes beavers are tough
animals that's all I'll say there so so
you trap them further first I do so
Beaver you can get a few things out of
them so Beaver you can get their fur
which every animal skulls are kind of
popular nowadays for some reason I don't
get it but and then there's a stuff
called beaver glands which is beaver
caster which has made they make perfumes
out of it imitation vanilla
um
there's a couple other things to do with
it but anyway Beaver caster and so you
got their butt and then they'll have
glands right behind it right here and
those glands if you get I mean they're
worth money too well they're worth good
good money you get a pound of glass
they're probably
in my area it's gold for about a
thousand dollars I'd say you know last
year it was anyway so glands are really
the only way you're making money off of
a beaver or just to try to get your gas
money back from the whole season
whatever you know
so to catch another Beaver though you
also use a beaver's gland so like I'll
buy
like I could buy it from another County
over just another Beaver for another
Trapper County over what if there is one
and you get another beaver's gland and
you rub that in that beaver's area well
it does a lot of things to that Beaver
like that Beaver just it's gonna go and
investigate that area whatever because
it can make the beaver mad it can make
them happy it can make them just what
the hell is that spell it can make them
want to mate it can make them I mean
there's a bunch of different reasons why
that Beaver is going to go over there
and investigate that area
so you do that and and not you know
people they don't know a lot about
trapping they you know they'll see you
go there and smear some Beaver Caster on
thing well that's not a magical that's
not a magical potion where it's like hey
come here Mr Beaver no you know these
Beaver you could have three traps in
that spot not Beaver never step in a
single one of them you know it it's it's
incredible I mean the amount of
intelligence they have per se I mean I'm
not saying they're stupid animals or
anything but it's just it's insane I
mean it's like they can what they're
really doing over there too is they can
smell your scent when you're going to
Beaver's area I mean you gotta think
that's like that's like somebody coming
home from a poop factory you know and
walking in the door like we're not gonna
smell you you know what I mean like
they're gonna smell you you know you
enter even in waiters you know I wear
the rubber waiter they're gonna smell
you there's no escaping that and otters
otters are even worse so in Indiana
you're allowed two otters a year
and
otters are definitely the meanest
nastiest
toughest animal I deal with an Indiana
person Coons they're tough too but I'm
talking water trapping
God
otters are definitely the
and I'm not talking about these little
cute little Tick Tock otters people are
seeing on their phone no these are river
otters and these things I mean I caught
one last year and he he was not I mean
he had dug like a five foot hole all
around probably a 15-foot Circle I mean
it was he was mad these these otter or
not it's there's and what people don't
realize there's 15 different species of
otters there's not just a single you
know they're sea otters river otters
there's all sorts of otters but these
otters that we have today they're real
long and skinny and the real I mean
they're all muscle the whole thing their
whole body's muscle they're like Runners
you know
and they're ninjas you could have 15
otters in an area around mud everything
you won't even know they're there and it
is the attraction to hunting
and trapping is it um
part you know you mentioned you're into
history is that part of it it's very
much part of it so I got into trapping
because of like a set of history and
stuff like that but also I reenact so I
do like 1812 reenacting there's a
there's a reenactment in my place is
called Messina wall of 1812 it's the
biggest 1812 reenactment in America that
I'm aware of like I don't think there's
a bigger one in US I mean we're it's
like 1200 reenactors and I could be
downplaying tonight but I mean there's a
ton of reenactors at this place so I
started doing that and that's one thing
I'm really big into is reenacting
historic reenacting
I betray a 1810 Canadian trapper
how did you first get into it
um seeing fur I've always been in the
fur I've always loved fur I mean I I've
always been and you know growing up I
had a lot of family from Big Stone Gap
Virginia and like down in the
Appalachians you know so we they moved
up to Wabash
and where I'm from and
just growing up always just saw like
deer fur on the couch or like I remember
my uncle he had a um
oh
well I don't know if it was a Croc
alligator I don't know but it was always
on the back of the couch and I was
always fascinated with that stuff
because I'm kind of into like the weird
Oddity things and you know just strange
things
and I just remember just sitting there
on a fur like I said like going into the
history and like reading about trapping
and like all this stuff I'm like how the
hell these guys get you know like a live
animal from me holding this right in my
hand you know like it was just it always
mind-boggled me so in a way
it was just kind of
I took that extra step to try to like
get that interest you know but also at
the same time like uh ever since I can
go back I've always been in the history
and like that's also why I got into
reenacting like I wanted to show people
like
this really is what history was this is
how Everyday People Like Us you know
live their lives in like eight and did
stuff and
so I think a lot of people can over
complicate it but it I mean it's it
sounds like in your life it's an
interesting contrast or an interesting
escape from what your family was was all
about yeah so it's always kind of been
like that like that's even in college
like with the cooking I
I had a chef chef Lou zadder was his
name
honestly in high school I joined the um
there's like this uh oh I can't think of
the name like a
a career center we could go to where you
could do like culinary robotics you know
diesel engines stuff like that we had
one of those centers so my senior year I
joined culinary because I was like
I'll make cookies you know what I mean I
was like I'll make some cookies and
brownies for school or whatnot that's
literally was my thought going into it
and I was in that class and
we had like a competition like a cooking
competition and I never I never I warmed
up pizza rolls in the oven you know what
I mean like I didn't realize I could
cook and so I just cooked it up and Chef
loser walked up to me he's like hey he
goes I'm being serious he goes you got a
touch for cooking and I was like
whatever and so he gave me this recipe
to make so he put me on the competition
team which I won I found one a full ride
scholarship to college from that which
blew my mind you know what I mean I was
like huh so I got that I went to college
I went to Louisville so you got to think
I mean I went from a town that had 10
000 people to go into Louisville that
had two million people I mean I lost my
ever love a month you know what I mean I
was like holy [__] my town shuts down at
nine o'clock man last night I was riding
my bike I get off work late I was riding
my bike I got stopped at 10 o'clock at
night by a police officer what are you
doing ride my bike I had to search me
and everything just because it's not I
live in a very very small town
like a very very small town you know
which I'm not hating on it I love it but
it's sometimes there's there's things
that I've gotten older now that
they're stuck in their ways we're still
stuck back in 1940 you know what I mean
we're still stuck way back in time way
back in time you know and
so but anyway to get back on the story
when I went to college it kind of opened
my eyes to like
like my best friend was Vietnamese I
mean he had only been in America for
three years you know his name's Martin
so out in Nashville or Nashville
Tennessee he's a sushi chef
but um he opened my he opened my eyes a
lot of stuff because it was like I had
you know I'm a Small Town Country kid
and then it was like you put me with
somebody that's literally only been in
America for three years for Vietnam and
I don't know if you know anything about
one thing I loved about him he smoked
cigarettes like I mean I've never seen
somebody smoke cigarettes like my friend
Martin Smoked Cigarettes loves loves
loves and loves but anyway we're both in
culinary school so that always drew me
to like once I got with Martin he kind
of opened my eyes so like especially
Vietnamese food that's my all-time
favorite food of all time Vietnamese I
love Vietnamese food but then I met the
mother of my child Grace and she's
Korean
so I kind of like in college I
definitely spent and then my best friend
um Kenny
uh he died they found him in our on our
old um he died of a heart aneurysm he
was 19 years old he was my best friend
in college but we were roommates and
stuff like that so like I had a lot of
like weird stuff happen in college too
but also like met a lot of incredible
people that
I would have never you don't like me
that Wabash were very I love my town
like I said but everybody there is very
simple complex money like it's very like
hey go get a job let's marry this girl
let's have a couple kids let's go to
church every Sunday and that's fine and
I love people that live like that you
know that's America's
world that's what makes America honest
people like that you know but it's like
for me I'm a very complex individual so
like one day yeah I might want to chill
at home but the next day I might want to
go out and trap Beaver or the next day I
might go up to Fort Wayne and like go to
a museum I'm just a very not all over
the place but I can't set still I can't
I'm not I can't you you can't ground me
to an area you know what I mean one of
my favorite sayings is uh curiosity is
the key to my frequency like I can't I'm
a very curious cat you know like if
there's something I don't judge people
you could tell me I'm like you in a way
like you could all walks of life man
I'll talk to you all day long might not
hang out with you but I'll talk to you
you know so there's just a lot of things
where it's like and I feel like um
being the way I am I'm very alone all
the time I'm alone all the time I have
good friends I go hang out with friends
I have you know good relationships with
people but at the end of the day I'm by
myself and I don't
no disrespect anybody but I don't trust
anybody with like my personal life and
like what I want to do like I my
happiness is on me you know what I mean
and like if you can't have that then I I
I just there's
I'm a very bold person so like if
there's something I don't like about a
person I'm not gonna tell them per se if
I'm just gonna walk up and leave like I
don't need to be here you know what I
mean and I feel like maybe my generation
has lost that a little bit like that
they can stand a lot of stuff and they
can like they can put up with a lot of
fakeness I cannot
I'm a very like Mana I don't like like
the typical like going out to LA that
kill me man I got a buddy out there in
L.A love them to death Aries I love
Aries to death but it would kill me to
go to L.A like I can't deal with like
the the
like oh everybody look at me look at my
thousand you know or this is what really
kills me starting to get way off topic
but the same people that judge me for
trapping and stuff are the same people
that want that ten thousand dollar
Birkin bag made out of beaver tail you
know it's like
that messes with me sometimes or like
I'll get a lot of people that call me
sicko and I mean I've told I wasn't
supposed to be born because I want to
trap some damn Beaver you know what I
mean but I don't get on you guys for
wanting to go out and take Molly and
drugs and party every weekend but if I
want to live a simple life and trap some
Beaver then I got a problem it just
there's a lot of stuff in my mind where
I'm just like all right you know what I
mean just like you live your life I'll
live my life you know and then like
going over things like growing up I do
have an older brother
so senior year he came out as trans so
he's trained he's a girl now
my little sister love her to death she
graduated she's a stripper up in
I don't know where she's at to be honest
she's in Ohio somewhere ran off of some
dude you know then you know you got my
poor Grandpa he was on crack for the
last 15 years of my life he raised it
much I thought I'm not talking poop
about the old man he did do all this
stuff but I mean he was a functional
crack addict let's put it that way you
know I mean we always had food and we
always had you know clothes and stuff
but there was no like when it came to
like
like I gotta you know I see all my
friends they go on trips to their
families and you know like I never had
that tell the mother of my child like
her family they I mean they brought me
in they saw we went to New York we went
I mean
you know what I mean it was just like
holy it was like the first time seeing
like a family put together and it
weirded me out I mean the whole time I
was just like what this is weird but it
wasn't weird it was normal but to me it
was weird you know so it's like
uh uh stuff like that like I see like
maybe that's what's normal to some
people was very weird to a person like
me like sitting down at a family table
and like you or like the
the mother of my child she would like
tell her parents stuff and I'm like why
the hell are you telling them that stuff
you know what I mean but I never
that is stuff you tell your parent you
know what I mean it was just sometimes I
was like what the hell like that's still
mind-boggling to me you know we're like
being close to your siblings I love my
siblings to death but with my older
brother being trans
our lives are he's over here and I'm way
over here you know what I mean love him
to death but my little sister same way
it's like
so it's like no matter how
what I've tried I've always felt alone
I've always felt like at the end of the
day I'm sitting right here in this seat
by myself you know and I'm totally fine
with that
um I'm the type of guy man I'm telling
you I don't
I'm a very um
complex system in my own mind I feel
like I'm on a thousand and everybody
else around me is on 50. you know what I
mean sometimes not all the time I like
people meeting higher energy people like
I just feel like my circuits liar you
have one child yeah I have one daughter
yep and you're raising her her mom
raises her so that's
that's kind of a touchy subject for me
um
me and her mom did great for like the
first year we lived with her parents by
the way so you know like there was I was
all the way in Cleveland Ohio
so I was five hours away from any of my
family
um
we were in we lived in Louisville before
all this like and then covet happened so
when covet happened
um she was always talking about wanting
to go back to her parents and stuff and
I've and I don't want to get the story
wrong but there was just we needed to go
back to Ohio she was having a baby my
life like I'll just explained obviously
we cannot I mean we could have but
she comes from a very good family you
know she was adopted she has a very good
brother I mean she has a sister I mean
her both her parents are lawyers you
know they're very
trusting people they're very good people
so
I don't
my daughter she lives four hours away
from me and I do go see her it's not
like I don't go see her but there I mean
man the man there are some things I
could do better you know personally but
there's not to put this wrong but
there's sometimes I feel like you don't
have to say anything for somebody to
catch a hand and there's sometimes when
I'm there where it's like I'm not needed
you know which I am her dad I know that
I'm needed and stuff like that but
there's sometimes where I feel like you
know she's all right so which
is older and like I can I guess
do what I need to do there
I think she'll understand
personally you know there's some things
that
I don't know how to explain it there's
just it's I feel like I've been told to
stay away if that makes sense you know
so
I feel like they don't
me and Grace we
I mean we were in love you know that was
the first score I ever looked at was
like damn she she could be the mother of
my child like I never
and uh if you want to be honest with you
man I've
I've had plenty of experiences with
women you know I've had my fair share of
women you know I'm not a womanizer or
anything like that but after I had my
daughter I slowed down you know when I
went to college man I'm from a small
town you know I had one girlfriend in
high school you know we were together
for whatever
so when I went to college you know there
was black girls there was Asian girls
there was white girls
I lost my ever love a [__] mind you
know what I mean so I was like holy [__]
you know my old town we don't I wasn't
raised around it was all white people
and I feel guilty for kind of saying
that sometimes but it's like that's what
it was you know I didn't
I saw black people when I went to like
my cancer checkups in Indianapolis that
was it you know what I mean now I mean
our town is very diverse but before I'm
telling you growing up we had one black
kid and one Asian kid that was it you
know so when I went to Louisville and
saw all the different races I was like
holy you know what I mean I was just
like wow
so I mean I I fell in love with the
Asian Community for sure but I feel like
the Asian people they're very um I like
them they're not they don't they don't
take [__] you know what I mean and they
they can certify
you can give a whole family of Asian
people 50 and they're gonna survive it's
insane I mean the way Martin taught me
how to live because I in college I was
like dude I'm sick of being broke I was
like I'm sick of you know what I mean us
oh he's working and we can't even go
like get a damn ice cream down the road
oh you're in college to work a full-time
but it's like still
so I remember him saying to me he was
like you want to know how to live
because we can still go out and have fun
so I'm not lying me and Martin and I
know he remembers this I mean we ate
rice eggs and hoisin sauce for probably
two months and plus we were in culinary
school so that really helped because
like the stuff we cooked we could take
home so that and we worked in
restaurants so food was always around it
was just like when you work in food you
don't want to eat you know people like
they always ask me because I work in a
very you know a nice establishment and
they're always like oh I bet you eat a
nice filet and I'm like no dude I go
home and warm up pizza rolls you know
what I mean like when you're when you
cook the food all day long I'm not
cooking it for me I'm cooking it for
other people so when you smell like you
know garlic like all that stuff all day
long it's just like no
you know they would think no it's like I
go home and I warm up a microwave dinner
you're working in a restaurant now yeah
I'm an executive chef now yeah so there
is there there is and with culinary two
that's one thing I really really like
it's like a very
it gives you a chance to be expressful
in a way that kind of like photography
you know you can when I make that play
it's not only about thinking about like
what the plate looks like I'm thinking
about what that first person's bite's
gonna look like or taste like and like
what the feeling they're gonna get off
that plate and like you know just the
overall experience they have just off
this one plate you know what I mean and
I think that's a beautiful thing because
you can go back from the very beginning
of time and people have been eating food
you know what I mean so food's never
going anywhere I don't think well I
don't know but you know maybe we'll all
be taking pills in a couple years you
know like one pill a day or so I don't
know but yeah it's it's insane it's it's
a very very
different life I would say you're an
interesting young man you're 26 right
yep I just turned 26 on August 16th
happy birthday thank you Braxton movies
you say is the most important lesson
you've learned in your 26 years
the most important lesson I've learned
in 26 years
I got actually two the first one I would
say and I've even had trouble with this
so I'm kind of not lately now that I've
gotten older but don't judge a book by
its cover you know
you know so like a lot of people see me
I'm bald you know I have stretch ears I
have the tattoos and stuff it's like
I've never done a drug in my life I've
never been arrested in my life you know
but I get a lot of hate I get a lot of
people judging me and especially in my
town like they'll hear one rumor about
you and then that's what they stick with
and then they meet you now they're like
oh you're pretty cool what and it's like
yeah dude you never talk to me you know
so it's like I never judge a book by its
cover and I think you should always even
if you don't think you have something in
common maybe grab a drink with the dude
that you've seen at work every day for
the last five years and you may think
he's a little weird well you might have
more in common with that guy than you
think you know what I mean
and then two
treat people how you would like to be
treated at all times and if you want to
be treated like [__] well then you go
ahead and treat people like [__] if you
want to be happy then be happy you know
what I mean so there's a lot of stuff I
think we could change in the world with
it and it doesn't have to involve race
color shape size whatever just say hey
have a good day you know nice to meet
you
um stay off your phones please
which I don't think that's ever going to
happen especially with technology if you
want to know something that will get me
going to technology man love it to death
helped us out but
it's definitely killed our society
that's really that's where we started
this talk all right Braxton thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
you're a fascinating young man thank you
good luck with everything thank you